e
good morning welcome is the committee on
housing we're going to get started if
you'd like to shut the door go
ahead um let's get started with the
I pledge aliance to the flag of the
United States of America to the Republic
for which stands one nation under God
indivisible with liy and justice for
all all right so today is meant to be
very very informal um this is an
opportunity for the committee to work
through um some of the bills that we
heard that we have already had a public
hearing on um so I have another number
of bills that
um I have noticed that I think we should
talk about as a full committee um and I
believe representative Howland has a
work session for a bill that we that we
um sent to subcommittee at 2:00 but um
my plan is to hopefully get through this
around 12:30 12:45 and then send you all
home unless you're on the subcommittee
and then you know so we might not break
for lunch I'm just going to try to power
through
this um
so for the newer members this is a great
opportunity for you to um just kind of
look at look at the legislation if you
have edits or something You' like to say
about it this is done in public so feel
free to add um input we're not taking
any votes on these bills today but I'd
like to know how the
what YouTube's on yeah YouTube's on yep
um I'd like to know how the committee
feels about these bills and some of the
changes so I've brought quite a number
of recommended changes to um the bills
that I introduced last week but um I
guess we'll just go right in numerical
order so um the first bill I have is HB
296 um if the committee me remembers
last week that or a couple weeks ago
that was representative Lads bill um
relative to private roads um I'm
relatively supportive of the concept I
think that it needs an amendment U my my
personal recommendation as chair is that
we amend it to only allow the local
government to review if a
emergency vehicle can access the private
road I think that was what we heard from
the public hearing was the only like
necessity of a private road like you
know what what's the municipality's
interest in regulating private road I
think to at least allow emergency
vehicle access but I'm open to the open
to suggestions from the committee
representative
Grant I agree that that's probably one
of the most important um in my question
the other day on this particular thing
the other thing I was getting at is the
maintenance of the road how are we going
to guarantee or how how's the town going
to get a guarantee that that Road's
going to be maintained so that a
emergency vehicle can get in there on
the fire department for 20 years you get
on a small Road like that the first one
gets stuck you're done yeah
representative um
jont what I've seen a lot of times with
newly created private roads is that the
towns are actually requiring them to
build build them to town stand ards or
per regulations and I think this is a
good idea and one thing that would make
it a little bit beneficial is if the
town is built to town standards which
would satisfy that representative's
issue um the town would have to
acknowledge those frontages along those
along those roads a lot of times right
now that's the at least what I've seen
the main hurdle is that the frontage
isn't acknowledged on something other
than a u you know a town-owned
highway represent Howen uh so that's
exactly my point uh so that RSA uh 231
colon 81- a is like maintenance of
private roads I actually have a cabin on
a private road and the difficulty we
have is that there's there is no
document right now that actually
regulates the maintenance of the private
road it's kind of like an urban legend
uh $400 that stayed that way for five
years and believe it or not my wife is
actually the collector of the money and
so it gets really difficult when the
properties turn over in uh to do you
maintain it I my neighbor who will
remain nameless one of them will not pay
the road fee in theory we can sue them
if for not paying it but it's really
messy um in terms of uh emergency
vehicles getting there in the winter
down my road that's why you have to have
an extra insurance waiver on there for
fire because if there's a fire your
house is going to burn down it's like we
do plow but forget about it so I think
the biggest uh thing I would change
along your lines too is that we just add
the word existing um if you want to
bypass the planning board on existing uh
private roads that's fine they the T the
town actually has you still fall under
the town's building permit stuff and on
our road there's been a lot of building
that has occurred my neighbor did a new
garage with a office over the top and
there's been two new houses that have
been built um so that's fine I think the
bigger issue you're going to have with
permitting on the road for us s you're
probably going to have to pull a
shoreline protection uh permit and the
state you're probably going to have to
pull you definitely going to have to
pull a septic permit so the permitting
doesn't seem to be an issue it's the
maintenance of the road uh and in the
spring if you come in and you're going
to build that road and the uh or you're
going to build the new house and the
road is soft and you damage the road
bringing in a big truck who pays for the
fixing of it so that's my issue
hopefully you don't if you do New Roads
please don't do it that way because it's
in other
feedback um so representative Howland
yes do you have um
recommended changes to this bill or I
think it's one word existing roads right
um it would be on the last line where it
says um has voted to authorize the
issuance of building permits for the
erection of build uh erection of
buildings on said on said existing
question okay yep represent page Al
would you want it in the
prior passage as well after after
establishing that the existing private
road yeah put at both spots yeah well
there was a a grammatical change too
right because on line four it says after
establishing that the private road
identified complies with so scratch and
and then say complies
with okay so two existing
are you volunteering to draft an
amendment sure
sure
great represent buo yeah I was I was
just going to say that I you know I
think the testimony that we got from
attorney Paul Alano um in his proposed
um amendment to this legislation I think
was actually really really really
insightful because I you know I'm I know
that his practice deals with this
specific issue frequently and I think
that you know just the simple you know
or you know uh just the or after
determining the road is suitable
condition for travel by emergency
vehicles I think that pretty much does
it I understand your concern about you
know maintaining you know an existing
private road or if there's a new private
road or whatever um but I think that you
know this legislation as contemplated is
really targeted at fixing this one issue
um you know if you add it in existing I
don't know if the legislation would be
as imp F but I also don't know you know
given the entire rest of the statute
what the impact of that would be um you
know as drafted it doesn't say anything
about existing or not it just says the
road um so I mean I would be in favor of
just a nice clean Amendment saying let's
just see that it's suitable for travel
by emergency vehicles and then move
on representative Dumont then
Paige I would agree I've always thought
this was a funny issue I don't see an
problem on the local level or at the
state level of uh a private road being
allowed the same rights as one that's on
a public Highway a lot of times what
happens is the individuals that own the
parcels along those private roads
typically have an HOA developed or they
have deed um they have incumbrances on
the deed that say what they need to do
to maintain that um and I don't think
there's a problem with allowing people
to choose how they want to maintain that
road um it it's a difference it's a
different kind of property but very
rarely do you see uh um larger issues I
think there's issues all across the
place but I don't think it's just
specific to private
roads represent paage thank you
so I'm just trying
to I don't feel particularly strongly
about this bill one way or another and I
think many of us um feel the same way I
just want to make sure that we are
understanding the sponsor's intent and I
think the the the amendment that Paul
alfano supplied to us as some as a
potential
amendment I mean I feel like it it
really changes the intent of the bill
I'm not saying we should not consider it
but you know the bill basically cuts out
this review and comment by the planning
board piece right and
um and this am this amendment would
leave that part intact so I'm not I
don't feel strongly about it one way or
another but I just want to make sure
that we are recognizing what the sponsor
intended to do with the bill
because I think that alfano amendment is
something
different um representative
Axton
so I have a property very very similar
to what uh representative Howen
described it's on a 50 or 60 year old
private road and we get a bill and you
can pay it not pay it whatever floats
your boat and in the spring they we we
have a gate and they CL the road there
are probably a dozen houses on the road
it's a very nice little
Community my there are one or two
building Lots there so my concern this
is in the let let us do no harm in the
attempt to do good category my my
concerns are I don't feel particularly
badly about the bill but I think uh my
concern would be in in my
case the if if I went to pull a building
permit to build on the lot adjacent to
me uh the town of Fitz William would
likely issue it subject to the
appropriate wetlands and septic designs
but it would never go to the planning
board because it's a it's a existing lot
of
record uh there is one next to my house
and so my concern is that we're if I
read this correctly we're now almost
required ing that everything go to the
planning board and I I don't know and I
can tell you for a fact that uh in the
case of my road it's not suitable for
turning a firet truck around
in uh it's quite quite the effort to get
a firetruck down there back it up it's a
like a 18-point turn when you get to the
end of it so uh because when you get to
the end there's there's a guy has a
tennis court there it's a lovely house
but so my concern is that we are able to
exclude this from at least from existing
private roads that would be an issue a
concern um I was yeah I miss Burns
you're in the room hello do you mind
coming up and um talking with us briefly
about
this can you remind me of nh's position
I believe you had recommended changes to
this yes we were actually in support um
of House Bill 296 we had the recommended
grammatical change which you've already
noted um I was not able to stay for
attorney Alfano's uh testimony so I
haven't seen the language that he
suggested I we are generally in support
because we think it gives another option
another way for uh towns to approve
building on uh private RADS right right
now as you've noted it's after review
and comment by the planning board uh but
approved by the governing body so this
would give them an option to actually
set a governing body policy and it could
go directly through the governing body
rather through the standard review and
comment by the planning board and then
approval by the governing body so in
that way it creates potential new
flexibility that may be positive for a
community um I've heard some comments
about one of the interesting things
about this statute is the question of
why the planning board is involved in
reviewing building on private roads
Because unless you have a change of use
to a multif family or to a business
you're not involving the planning board
right the planning board's not involved
in approving your your single family you
know building the reason that I think
the main reason the planning board is in
this statute is there's a concept called
premature and Scattered development and
part of what I think the statute is
trying to do is give the planning board
the ability to weigh in and say you know
know we don't have any homes over in
that area and if you put uh that one
home on that private road 20 mi away
from the next you know bit of
civilization we're going to start
creating this scattered uh development
kind of concept in the town and and
that's not uh maybe that's not positive
for health and safety I I think that's
part of the reason the planning board is
involved here is to give that comment
and they can't Trump the select board
they review and comment under the
current statute but they can't override
the governing body's ability to approve
these building permits um but to your
original question yes we were supportive
we think it's just another mechanism
okay and I have a I have a question um I
don't remember who this was but there
was public testimony um talking about
amending this with the same Lang
language for class six roads yes I I
mentioned that that you might want to uh
thank you that you might want to miror
the previous paragraph RSA yes correct
and that it might make sense to do that
they are two different types of roads
but the idea is that they are both non
municipally maintained roads so they
have their own concerns with respect to
adding new homes can you talk to me
about the what the current law states
around Classics roads if that is similar
to this one it's almost the same
language there might just be I could
pull it up on my I I could pull it up
language but I know you have it there in
you
okay does that yes that helps are there
other questions Miss
Burns thank you appreciate your help um
so how's the commit you feel about
making those recommended
changes to C1 in the RSA right before
adding class six represent Howland so
I'm I mean to her Point that's why I put
existing the existing Pro the existing
Road you probably already did a
subdivision right I mean the
theoretically there is a property out
there that you could subdivide maybe but
the road already exists and to
representative dumont's point I I think
most plan boards that are sayane when
you go into a subdivision regulation
you're not it's not like YouTube where
they have like this remote cabin out 20
miles and there's this winding road that
somehow you get out there you really
don't want to do that and so I'm hopeful
that most planning boards are sane
enough not to do that that you really do
have have thought through what the road
is how it's scattered but unfortunately
the existing roads already exist and
it's like they the existing Road
shouldn't have to go through the
planning board anyway if you have if
they've already done the subdivision
regulation with it and you're going to
get a building permit on that existing
Private Road you should just be
following what the municipality said are
the rules it should be pretty
streamlined uh again as I said you're
probably if it's waterbased which
there's a lot of these up on the Lakes
Region you're going to be pulling state
permits for the septic and the shoreline
permit for sure you know when you look
at it as a state permit so I just think
they're a separate animal and and
there's a cautionary tale about it
because while our road has been really
wellmaintained across the way they are
fighting about it they definitely need
to do some drainage and probably put in
a culvert and they don't want to spend
the money in the road you could get an
emergency vehicle in there a car is a
little hairy but to your point our road
is the same way in the winter time to
get there with a fire truck you're going
to have I think you're probably going to
have to have DPW comeing with a plow
truck first and salt it and then get
your fire truck in there and even when
you got the fire truck in there there's
nowhere to pump you they chop a hole in
the lake maybe and I try to pump by
which time your house will have already
point okay so where we at with
this representative
Dumont I think for existing Lots this
would satisfy that but I guess the issue
that I that I think is more more
important is a lot of times
municipalities currently don't want to
take over New Roads that are created and
when they don't want to take over New
Roads that are created that creates
private roads and most subdivision or
ordinances that are that are written
don't acknowledge private roads as legal
Frontage and I think that this bill
could fix two issues I think it could
fix that issue as well as acknowledging
Frontage on private roads for for uh new
subdivisions to be to be
representative acent do you have
something well I I mean I don't think
any of this is mutually exclusive I
think you're fixing you can fix the one
problem I think you need to we need to
reward just a little bit put existing
Road in there and leave that out it's a
interesting the the description of the
various issues that in in in the towns
that I represent I could I can give a
handful of examples of a house literally
a mile down a Class 6 Road 3,000 ft off
of the class 6 Road and so these things
are out there and I think it's important
to leave the and if it burns it burns
it okay so um in my position of
Delegation as chair I'm going to
delegate representative Dumont and
Howland to work out an amendment and
come back to us if that works all right
right great okay let's move on to HB
382 um that is one that is near and dear
to my heart but I want to know how the
committee feels about this that's
removing the Authority for
municipalities to regulate mandatory
on-site parking requirements um where's
everybody at with that representative
howand I'm actually gonna call on you
first because you have an
amendment um so I uh I did amend it and
I think I passed all my amendments
around there I tried to T tried to
simplify it I'm not trying to be onerous
as a
municipality doing requiring so much
parking that you can't build anything I
think the idea that municipalities don't
have a good idea about what's going on
with parking is definitely not true in
my six years on the Town Council parking
probably was the biggest issue I ever
talked about um so I tried to simplify
and say you only needed under the
statute the first part of it dealt with
Workforce housing the uh the uh I think
it's a studio and one bedroom and I cut
the requirement down to just one uh
parking spot per per unit there and then
the second part dealt with
multifam uh initially they said the
multif family requirement was 10 units I
cut it down to five five is kind of a
more natural Breaking Point with multif
family the financing from four to five
changes and a lot of Regulation changes
and with that I also said you only need
one space per unit in that five unit or
more development and then I said the
next thing is that you can if you do
off-site parking that can meet all your
parking requirement the only reason I
really wanted that in there is um in in
our case particularly in our downtown
area uh you're subject to the ms4 permit
that you get which is completely
non-negotiable uh and for us uh when you
have all those impervious surfaces down
there it becomes a it's just
economically unfeasible for
redevelopment of a building to make them
do the on-site and so we definitely want
to do offsite but the offsite may
actually in our case be structured
parking and so in that case we just want
to have the municipality just wants the
ability to negotiate with our
developers uh that we may do onsite we
probably may want to think about a tiff
and use the raised assessment kind of
pay for it along with par with uh with
parking fees and so this would
facilitate I think that those
conversation it doesn't put an onerous
requirement on the developer but it also
allows us to have a seat at the table to
negotiate and so I made the changes in
how much you required and then the
effective date I pushed over to
2026 the only reason I did that is
because right now if you're in SP2 town
or you do your town meeting you don't
have any ability to react and so this
this would give you time theoretically
to put a warrant on uh I would suggest
that your municipality maybe looks at
what off-site parking would look like if
you need a tiff if you're going to do
parking impact fees what that would look
like and it would give you time to react
to the ordinance so that that that was
my thoughts so um with regards to
pushing the effective date out what
happens when a municipality does not
vote for the change it it it is what it
is right yeah yeah I'm just trying to
give them
I think honestly uh besides the parking
I really want you to look at financing
and your planning department to kind of
look at the development because it's not
a mystery you probably are trying to
figure out particularly if you're doing
structured parking which is brutally
expensive how are you going to pay for
it and I mean the idea really for the
mun the idea that the municipality
doesn't want development I hope is wrong
I mean we're really looking to maximize
the value of the land so that when we
tax you we can kind of stabilize your
your property tax rates so this is just
a negotiating uh point I think so to
give you a little history on parking um
last year the special committee on
housing had a bill relative to parking
it was solely for residential but it
would only allow one parking space per
unit and it did not dis it did not have
any more stipulations other than that
and that was passed out of the committee
and actually went through the house on
consent and then the Senate amended it
and added squatting and other other
things onto the bill to be more creative
um so the the area that was affected was
what you're talking about um 674 67416
Senator Bradley was really interested in
adding um Workforce housing and and
other stuff to it I I personally think
it muddies it up when we start
defining what uh what H what housing you
can regulate parking in how many spaces
like I'd like at least consistency make
it more clear I think the bill has
drafted makes it clear but I know that
um we might not be unanimous so I want
to know if there's like where we can
move on it to get to a point I hate to
word Smith but I was GNA say I like your
wording better just one space per unit
and you can use offsite to offset it I
think it's important to have the offsite
being able to offset it just because in
the situations I talked about if you
have an MS four permit that's not
letting you do that makes it unviable
for that developer you want them to be
able to use offsite to to to do that
even again one spot per unit does sound
like a little but if you can't add any
impervious surface to it you really want
offsite so I think that's an important
component so what about what about the
language of
one spot per unit unless the developer
can prove there's off-site parking
available
representative
Gibbs with reference to the provision on
work Workforce housing um your Amendment
provides one space per unit for studio
and one bedroom apartments why not just
um make it clear or or I think simpler
that one space per unit without limiting
that to studio and one-bedroom
apartments this a question I guess for
representative Howen I think that's bad
I noticed that too cuz what if you have
a two-bedroom apartment and also by the
way I left a hole there I said multif
family is five what if you have a
fourplex so the the one unit is that's
definitely much cleaner language one per
unit makes a one per unit and then allow
however you want to say offsite can can
so just one per unit not specifying what
size yeah thank you representative
Dumont and then representative Aaron
does anybody see a problem with how
local municipalities will interpret
offsite I see there being a bunch
there's just a see that creating a lot
of issues because some developer may
think that a couple blocks down the road
is is is satisfying that need while
other municipalities are going to tell
you that it has to be a direct abutting
property I think it's just going to
create a a problem of people
understanding what the intent here was I
truly believe that less is more with
this um I get it and I and I and I would
agree here I think it's a simple thing
but when it gets to the local level
there's going to be
problems represent Aon uh I'm very much
in favor of this amendment uh
representative Howland put forth because
it at least has some parking requirement
uh because my fear is that when you take
away the parking requirement then
they're just not going to put any
parking in and you'll have parking all
over the street uh and just create a
mess so this is great and the details no
problem okay represent Daxton and then
represent
buo uh I like the idea of the simpler
the better it's going to be less
confusing for planning
boards uh I generally am supportive of
the idea of offsite parking but in my
experience that in my part of the world
where we have had
larger uh
developments they have accept the
planning boards have all accepted
off-site parking so you know maybe this
is a problem I'm not aware of nobody had
to Define it they just said we didn't
have any rules and and and can see your
point coming over here to conquered so
if you say we have off-site parking as
members over at stores that kind of
might be a stretch if you're developing
a 4unit apartment building it's six
blocks away so uh but I think less is
more and I think the planning boards
have some level of competence in
judgment I don't think you need to
micromanage it represent buo yes thank
you um so may maybe I I missed something
because um you know now now that there's
this this amendment I I was honestly
very much in favor of the bill as it was
originally drafted and I mean you know
to be quite honest with you uh you know
I I I really think that you know we're
we're fretting about H is there not
going to be enough parking in New
Hampshire when the fact is as we already
know it's a fact there is not enough
housing in New Hampshire and the fact
that oh developer won't build enough
parking I mean the developer has an
incentive to build something that people
want to live in and I mean I think that
we don't need to pass a law to remind
people to breathe people will do it on
their own I don't think we need to pass
a law saying well you know we need this
minimum amount of parking maybe there
are neighborhoods where infill is a
really really good idea maybe there are
already historic walkable neighborhoods
to where shoehorning in a bunch of
parking is frankly not necessary so I
think that given the fact where we are
in the housing crisis I actually would
favor the original unamended bill and if
it becomes a we can walk it back later
but I say let's let people build the
housing that people want to buy first
represent
miles thank you Mr chairman um I
actually I Echo your comments Mr uh
representative buer um I think less is
more I was also very happy with the
original bill and I
think I
sorry respectfully I do think this
muddies up the water and puts in puts
puts regulations back in where we as a
committee our goal and what we promised
people was less regulations more freedom
to build and I think the original bill
was was okay as it was so let let me um
do it like an informal straw
poll um my first question is going to be
who is in favor of the bill
unamended and then my next question is
who would like to see the one space per
unit
language representative Dumont one final
question for you before that it's my
interpretation of this that it would
affect parking regulations for all uses
not just residential commercial and
residential yes so that not multif
family commercial but a site plan for a
strip mall or things of that nature yes
so um what would need to happen is we
would
do on the original
Bill lines 9 through 20 we would amend
it to add the one space per unit and
then after that we would keep the new
section regarding commercial
use as
is representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um originally I
supported the bill as written I didn't
think it was necessary to require
parking I figured Builders would build
um what people were willing to live in
and if people insisted on parking then
they would build parking um but um after
some private discussions particularly
with representative Howland um on the
difficulties that this might create um
for
municipalities um I was willing to go
with um the um uh essentially with the
amendment that uh representative Helen
proposed but learning Mak it just one
space per unit not making it more
complicated um because if it was really
going to cause problems for the
municipalities that's not we want what
we want to do
either Howen so I after hearing my wiser
planning board people talk about the
offsite they're they're they're right I
mean the municipality is going to do
while the planning board and then
actually up to whatever your local
governing body is going to do that
anyway I think with commercial or
anything like that you're going to when
you're looking at it how do you best
work it so they I mean doing the Tiff
all that is a separate issue and I agree
if I muddy the waters and talk about up
offsite then we're going to be how far
budding the one space is just cleaner
with okay so
um let me do a show of hands who's in
favor of the bill unamended raise your
okay who's in favor of um some sort of
language that would change lines 11
through 20
to um allow up to one space per
unit and keeping the same keeping the
language for the
hand who would vote for the bill as
amended if this language is in there
even if they don't necessarily like the
language I think I know I think I know
okay see that's see I no I I was
directing right at represent buolo so
okay all right so I think so I think
we're um at relative agreement so I'm G
to confir with representative Paige and
probably get an amendment drafted um for
okay all right next up is um HB
577 my firstborn
child um so I
organized okay so I handed around um HP
577 recommended edits so I'm just going
to run through these real
this was b a lot of this was based on
testimony during the public hearing um
number one would amend lines um 15 to 17
that would um municipality adopt a
zoning ordance pursuant to the authority
granted this chapter shall allow adus uh
that permits single family dwelling
um it it would basically say in any
municipality that does not have zoning
we do not need to require them to now
create zoning which I do not want to do
so the municipal association's looking
at me but yeah I don't want that either
so um that's what that would do n um the
second one is relative to square footage
um HP 577 removes the existing language
that would um require that a
municipality may not restrict Adu to
less than 750 square F feet um so this
would this language here would just add
in um
add it back in to allow it to be 750 to
950 square
feet and then the third component would
be relative to short-term rental and I'm
open to this but I think there was a
conversation around um short-term
rentals um I want to give municipalities
the
option um so I think the language that
says nothing in the section prohibits a
municipality from regulating short-term
rentals of less than 30 days allows them
the option um so you know um places like
where represented page represents might
have a different um utility for this
than other areas of the state so um
these are these are my proposals but I'm
open to the committee's feedback on the
language represent gont I just had a
question about the square footage I
always thought it was a funny thing to
throw in there because typically a lot
has a building envelope and you can
utilize the space that's within that
building envelope so why are we trying
to limit the size of an Adu if it is is
an accessory dwelling you know why do I
care how big somebody makes a well I I
understand and I support that concept
but the
but the definition of accessory means
that it's like extra like it's like I
just think it would be weird to build an
Adu that's larger than the existing
unit so I while I know it's your private
property right like I you know I support
that but I don't know it seems kind of
odd to me but go ahead follow up on that
wouldn't a simpler one just be that the
accessory dwelling unit must be smaller
than the
existing okay so if you're or not to
exceed the square footage of the
existing yeah yeah I said well well wait
a okay so if you have a 3,000 foot house
and you want to build a 2,950 square
foot Adu yeah what do I I mean to to
each their own I really what I like
versus what somebody else like are two
different things I okay
great okay represent Howen so believe it
or not I actually agree with that I
think you that the Adu is just
subservient to the main house is fine if
you can fit it within all of the your
setbacks everything else why not all of
the other regulations yeah okay well I I
just know how the house is as well and I
think this committee while I agree with
a lot of what this committee is saying I
think that the House of Representatives
might have an issue if we were to pass
something like that through this
committee so that's just my political
Acumen coming
come in a sense here I don't know if
necessarily people would like that very
much represent bolo no I mean I
definitely I definitely respect the
sentiment because you know I'd rather
get half of a good thing than you know
nothing at all if we're trying to be you
know too ambitious but I really do think
um and I definitely defer to your
political Acumen um but I mean it I
think there's a bipartisan consensus
that we're in a housing crisis let's
send something ambitious and let's see
if people are serious about actually
addressing it I think something like
well it's accessory but it's smaller I
think that's conceptually very easy to
understand it doesn't over-regulate and
it has the potential to actually create
even more housing than we were
anticipating with this legislation I
mean why not why not try
it represent Aon if you build an Adu
that's bigger than the main house and
the main house becomes the
Adu and you're still within the
regulations so this says Miss Burns can
you come up and and talk about maybe
language I think I'm being the voice of
reason
here I hope my facial expressions in the
back of the room weren't weren't too
excitable
um yes they were um when this bill when
the original Adu bill was passed in I
think it was
2016 we did work very closely with the
folks who passed the legislation to make
it um you retain some local control
ability but also to take to understand
that there was this will to have this
allowance of of adus on on single family
properties we raised the increase in
square footage issue in our letter to
the committee for the exact reason
that's been stated which is the idea
behind accessory dwelling units is that
they be accessory to the main use of the
property right and so if the main use of
the property is a single family home
then their accessor then their accessory
to that single family home use and
accessory uses are usually usually you
know incidental and subordinate are the
typical words that you see with respect
to what is an accessory use and so there
was an agreement on the 750 square foot
um would be a reasonable incidental and
subordinate uh structure size to the
primary single family home use um
certainly I understand uh the comments
made uh you know wanting to have a an an
aggressive uh Bill to send to the house
and also the idea that well isn't it
just accessory if it's smaller I don't
think it's just specifically about it
being just a tiny bit smaller than the
single family home it's about it being a
structure that is in fact not a single
family home but is of the same type of
use and fits in well with the existing
property and the existing structure so
you have a smaller structure you as a
residential use that is incidental and
subordinate is accessory to the primary
um home and that is how we settled on uh
the 750 square foot all of those years
ago I would say that based on what I
have heard this morning uh the potential
suggestions to amending the bill could
possibly even NH May would be willing to
work with the committee on those
suggestions and possibly even uh be able
to change our position I to neutral if
some of the suggestions were put into
place as we did in 2016 with the
original accessory dwelling unit Bill
the only other comment that we had
raised was that the current Adu statute
does allow the municipality to
allow one of the structures to be owner
occupied um I know I did not hear that
suggestion raay but that is another
suggestion uh that we would like to see
retained in in current language but
understand if that's not the will of the
committee thank you yeah representative
ryford okay I have two comments
questions um fundamentally I agree with
representative Aaron if I have a child
who wants to have an Adu on my property
but my existing home is smaller and they
have four children and they need a
bigger home why can I not stay in my
home and build a bigger one if it's if
it's my property and that would be
considered an Adu second piece of it is
are does this bill allow for if you have
say an existing structure on your house
like a barn you have the you have the
property you have a barn can you convert
a barn into a home that would be
considered an Adu if the structure is
already there yes I I I absolutely you
you just doesn't require you to build a
structure from the ground up you might
have a structure I have a giant shed um
on my property um that um I could
convert into an Adu if it if it met the
other requirements of the statute and
just with respect to to your first
comment and and the discussion about the
two structures and and how big they
should be I I would suggest for your
consideration that at that point if the
size of the second structure is allowed
to be so substantial the same size
substantially the same size bigger than
the single family home really what this
bill becomes is a bill about two homes
on a lot so instead of being Adu bill
it's a bill about allowing two homes on
a single lot so I just think it's a
different policy bill at that point I I
agree with your
position uh representative Paige are
there are these questions for Miss Burns
or we okay thank you for your thank you
for your testimony okay go ahead
representative
Gibbs and thank you Miss bur um isn't
the question about the size of the Adu
relative to size of the original house
um more a question about the definition
of the term accessory I mean the idea
that it has to be smaller in order to be
an accessory um what difference does it
make in reality as opposed to whether or
not it's an accessory I mean you can
call it anything you want but if it fits
on the lot and otherwise fits into
whatever um aesthetic uh requirements
may be applied why does it matter
whether it's bigger or smaller I think I
would go back to um what I said a few
moments ago BEC to it at some point just
becoming a an allowance for two homes on
one law as opposed to a single family
home and an accessory home that I I
think I would just go back to that that
being said I I do want to to say too
that even the existing law as well as uh
House Bill
577 they don't restrict a municipality
from allowing larger Adu structures if
they wished to if they wanted to Define
that differently or allow that
differently and of course when I say
they uh most of our municipalities it's
their Town meetings voting on these
zoning amendments so a town meeting
could adopt a different um a different
ceiling if they wish to um
and I also I I also just realized that
you may or may not want be supportive if
we move out the effective date a year oh
the moving out the effective date to
give them time to adopt that would be
that so you're you're just just to
clarify if I if we make these changes
nhma is switching to neutral on this
bill I will discuss that with my board
of directors I can have that discussion
if these suggestions are put into place
and the bill
becomes the bill retains local control
and the ability for these to be
regulated to be you know helpful for
Workforce housing like with the added
language potentially about short-term
rentals okay representative
ryford okay so if we're being specific
on a square footage size so this is 950
Y and we adopt that as a state so say
the bill goes through as is with 950 can
towns change that to be their whatever
their local requirement is because then
we get into a situation where you have
50 million different sizes that a
particular Town based on their
schematics would allow so even right now
a town could allow adus larger than 750
feet but they can't have their local
regulations say they have to be 600
square F feet so if I believe the way
House Bill 577 is written is that 750
950 becomes the new
750 so they wouldn't be allowed to
restrict them to smaller than 950t Lots
I uh uh structures I believe that's the
way the bill reads right now oh but they
could go larger that's correct they
could okay thank you yeah and and I I
agree with Miss Burns that this
committee can talk about having two
homes on a single family lot and we have
a whole another year for legislation so
representative buolo when you put that
bill in next year which I'm sure you
will um we will entertain that but I
think in order to keep the Adu bill I
think we should have the accessory
larger
unit I just represent buio thank you M
for thank you represent buo could could
we maybe do something where okay maybe
instead of not to exceed 950 sare ft to
maybe kind of keep the scale and
proportionality maybe say um I don't
know 75% or 2/3 or something like that
so that way it's definitely going to be
smaller and it's definitely going to be
clear that it's you know smaller but
it'll still fit with a scale of whatever
is there would that still be too too
aggressive or representative paage did
you have something oh in response to
that yeah oh I was I was just going to
Echo you as our chair saying I think we
have to be aware of the political
reality of getting this through so I'm
my my take is that we should scale it to
what we think we can achieve
so representative Dumont
I do understand that and I appreciate it
you know I think my point was made the
only I will say is you know I can get
behind this an improvement is an
improvement but you're not going to see
any municipalities go larger just like
for right now it's set at 750 square F
feet that's that's where they're all at
they're always going to take the Lesser
size so I wouldn't be too ambitious and
and hope that somebody's going to go
larger you set a square footage that's
what it'll be well and and the key the
key change remember with the 950 is it
adds the extra bedroom right so like
this I mean this is huge for the
disability Community say you want a
caretaker living in the same home as you
like I mean there's a lot of great
changes that come with 950 adding that
extra bedroom um is huge so I while
they're not going to go larger I think
two bedroom adus are are are necessary I
think in today's housing housing
climate so um represent
page thank you are we ready to move on
to a different topic quickly I'd like to
talk about the short-term rental piece
yeah um so I think um I appreciate the
draft language that we have
here and I appreciate your understanding
of my of my district I mean I'll say
canvasing this last summer was one of
the saddest things in the world to be in
neighborhoods where I knew there had
been a registered voter two years ago
and door after door being a short-term
rental I mean it's it's that's the
context in in which I come to this piece
of it um and recognizing how my
constituents feel about the way that's
transformed Our Town um so I think this
is a good start I would love to see this
um I would love to see this language be
more affirming of what municipalities
can do um I think I would love to you
know really clearly say that
municipalities can restrict um not just
that not just that we won't prohibit you
know because we've run into the issues
in Conway time and time again trying to
place to regulate short-term rentals I'd
like to really clearly State what
municipalities can do that we can
restrict um you know um you know
uh uh I'm losing the word not tency but
you know less than um transient uh uh
visitors of less than 30 days okay um
whether we do that you know say they can
do it via deed restriction or what have
you um the other piece for me here is
thinking about how folks
um maybe downsizing into their Adu also
thinking about the primary dwelling in
that equation because the goal is
housing right our goal here is housing
and so I want to make sure that we're
not having someone move into their new
new Adu and then short-term renting
their primary dwelling so those are my
two concerns that I want to make sure we
address in the final language of that
piece but just want to get that out
there okay I I think I I just this
language was suggested to me but I'm I'm
certainly if there's a a more clear
sentence that would satisfy it feel free
to let me know represent buo I was just
going to say I I like I like the
language as drafted because it keeps
this focused on adus and doesn't turn
this into a short-term rental bill so I
personally kind of like where it is one
of the things I will say in defense of
short-term rentals I mean you know the
fact is is New Hampshire you know makes
a lot of money from tourism and it's a
very important part of our economy and
the fact is is that especially in the
North Country if we were to completely
say you know what everybody hates
short-term rentals let's get rid of them
all so they can be housing instead you
really going to see this KnockOn effect
or you're going to have a lot less
tourism so that's going to be a lot less
people visiting local businesses there
going to be a lot less people going to
local restaurants the other thing I'll
say is that you know supply and demand
if there are too many short-term rental
units people will start converting those
into long-term and it really becomes a
pain in the neck if you're doing a
short-term rental and you got to change
the sheets every time and you'd have to
turn the unit there could be people who
say you know what I'm going to put an
Adu and I'm going to make it a
short-term rental they do it for a
little bit realize it sucks and then
they're going to say you know what this
is actually going to be long term and
I'm going to have people in here for a
year and I'm going to have a year-long
tenant so I think that you know although
I definitely sympathize with you know a
lot of the negative consequences of
short-term rentals I really think that
we should be very light and we should be
very gentle in terms of what we do as a
committee in terms of restricting
them represent Paige
I I hear that perspective I'll say again
from my very hyperlocal context
especially with the potential changes
around not not requiring one the primary
ding to be owner occupied I mean I get
at least twice a month you know
something in the mail from a company
that wants to buy my house to use it for
a short-term rental and the vast
majority of our short-term rentals in
Carol County are not own by people who
live in Carroll County um so I think you
know um my concern would be that both
units end up that way and I will say in
my community I don't know what it's like
in Littleton but in my community it
still seems the appetite for them is
insatiable um I mean we have entire
neighborhoods where you used to have
kids biking around on the street that
are now just party Villages so you know
that's my that's where I'm coming from
topic represent miles just a
clarification but isn't that something
your own municipality zoning board can
apply to that area to to rectify for
that geographical location I'm genuinely
asking the yes I will say it has been a
real struggle and we have continued to
struggle with that we have been to court
many times um as we've tried to address
that issue so what I am what I would
seek in this is very clear
um you know what what it says here what
scares me about the language as drafted
is that it just sort of says nothing
prohibits the mun municipality from
regulating I would really like to see
language affirming here are ways in
which municipalities can do this if that
makes sense it's a small tweak the
sentence that would say a municipality
May um in a municipality and its
discretion May regulate the accessory
dwelling unit not to be short-term
something like that okay just a fing it
all right I think I can come up with
that
other other Concepts representative
deont not a concept about short-term
rental but I had a couple other comments
go one um how does everybody feel about
uh municipality not being able to
restrict a secondary access um I've seen
a couple municipalities do that with the
adus um some have ordinances particular
that per lot you're only allowed one
driveway which in my opinion causes an
issue for emergency vehicles but also
depending on how you're utilizing
that and something as simple as you know
municipality shall not prohibit a
secondary access I think would
but representative Aaron I think that
makes sense because one of the biggest
things in this bill is that you're
allowing detached
and that that's a that's a real big plus
so you might want a separate driveway or
something like
that
okay go ahead I'm G to add one other
thing that I would like to see taken out
would be on page two line 23 I don't
think that we should be dictating
Aesthetics I yeah I understand yeah I
think uh Mr Mayberry said it best when I
think the idea is is you don't want want
the Adu to look like a pirate ship when
your original unit looks like a colonial
and I and I think that's the legislative
intent I I can understand that but I I
got to go back to what I like versus
what the other side likes are going to
be two different things yeah and I I
just I always find it funny when you
have board members telling people the
way that their house should look I I
just I think that common sense and the
market will really dictate that very
well sure you're going to have one-offs
but you're going to have that no matter
what okay represent Faxton I as the
veteran of numerous zba and planning
board hearings and nine years as a
selectman uh I share that concern
because while it seems perfectly
reasonable in here we don't want a
pirate ship standing behind a two-story
Colonial uh you haven't lived till
you've been in a zoning Board hearing or
a planning board hearing where the
argument is not whether you can build
the building or not but whether the
doors will be green or
blue uh and in my town that I live in we
are there is a a Redevelopment going on
of our former Woolen
Mill uh and the the biggest complaint
about it is many of the residents do not
like the color of the roof which is by
the way
black so you know I wouldn't want to
give that power to people to regulate
that represent howand actually it was
the shade of green actually down to the
shade of
green okay so how does the committee
feel about this aesthetic requirement
standard
here okay let me let me ask show hands
who's in support of the bill removing
the authority Miss's regul aesthetic
standards raise your
hand who remove to remove remove the
it yeah okay your question again reverse
no are you in favor of removing the the
municipality's right to regulate
aesthetic standards from of the
Adu if you're in favor of the removing
hand if you're opposed to
it letting them retain the ability raise
your
hand okay representative Paige I I want
to add sort of a third category there
which is please do which is also I don't
want to derail the bill I don't want to
derail the bill so I I would be in favor
of if of keeping it if we think that
improves our chances of moving it
through both the house and the Senate
yeah that's my take I you know and and I
really appreciate that this committee
wants to move forward on a lot of this
stuff and I hate to be the voice of
reason here but I think that we should
probably keep that part in the bill in
order to get it through the house and
the senate representative Dumont with
the show of hands I think it was there
was a good amount of consent there I
would be in favor of leaving alone with
this bill so long as there's some other
way to remove that Authority in the
future I I don't see how in any of the
zoning laws that was enacted Aesthetics
being a part of that it was always
always health and safety and it has gone
to a whole new level I have seen and
watched and sat through zoning board
meetings where there was a topic about
shutters it it it goes way too far and
that has nothing to do with that that
you know those properties being built
well and this committee has already
acted on a very important bill HB 399
that would establish a commission to
study the zoning enabling act so we can
talk about did the legislature intend to
give the responsibility of
municipalities to regulate shutters in
1925 I don't know but it's a it's
something that we will be discussing as
um that's all I'm going to say but I
understand what you're saying U
representative bolo then representative
Gibbs so one of my one of my concerns on
on this and I mean you you already know
which kind of you know points I'm going
to Echo about this but maybe one of the
ways where we could sort of keep
aesthetic standards in there if we
absolutely must I I agree with
representative dumont's comments I I
don't think it should be in here and I
don't think it's within purview of the
authority granted to towns to regulate
um zoning but what I'm really concerned
about is you know one of the best ways
in my mind to build accessory dwelling
units is if you use Innovative new
construction techniques practices let's
say you have prefabricated you know
construction let's say you have some
kind of modular construction or
something like that and municipalities
say you know what that's a really like
cost-effective way to build adus and we
actually hate adus and we don't want
them in our town at all but the
legislature is forcing us to have them
let's use a aesthetic standards as a
back way to prevent these things and say
well you can't use these materials and
you can't use this construction
technique and you can't do this you know
XYZ so maybe a car out to where okay if
we're going to have aesthetic standards
maybe not talk about construction
materials or techniques or something
like that what what about just adding
the word a municipality May apply
reasonable because here here's the thing
reason here's I I I think I think there
is a
clear definition for reasonable
and I think in some ways maybe the
courts will determine what reasonable is
but I think if we get if the 18 of us
got together and we're we're like that's
not reasonable right like like a bunch
of people would get together and be like
that's not a reasonable aesthetic
standard cuz what you're what you're
saying is unreasonable I think anybody
would think that maybe not a planning
board but that's up to the courts to
decide I mean if you have to go to court
you're already putting a major break and
impediment on construction because a lot
of people do they want to sign up for a
lawsuit no they want to build an
Adu represent Aon I'm sorry represent
Gibs thank you
um well I would also prefer that the
local Authority not not have the
authority to tell people what their
building should look like uh and
certainly not have the authority to tell
them what color the door should be or
the roof should be or whether or not it
should have shutters um I really think
that's going way too far um nevertheless
if we need the athletic standards in in
the uh proposed bill in order to get it
passed I would go along with
it represent Faxton
so as previously stated I have severe
concerns about the word Aesthetics in
here however I think by trying to fix it
by saying reasonable Aesthetics I think
you've created a WPA project for
lawyers uh so I would I would prefer if
if I have to go on the like what is the
least bad of my choices leave it as is
okay uh I think that if I was an
obstructionist select board or I was an
obstructionist planning board I would
grasp onto the aesthetic nature of this
and make it fundamentally impossible to
build an
Adu or so absurdly expensive and
inconvenient that it would it's and I
think you know there's a sense of
fairness for the most part in these
things and maybe that'll where it'll get
work if you're going to toss it where it
has to get worked out in court if you
really need Aesthetics in there to get
enough votes to get it over the hump
okay but I think I think you're leaving
a big opportunity for an obstructionist
planning board or select board to say
you know what blue houses are not
aesthetically pleasing we want
everything covered in Brick and I have
just for the record I have lived in
communities where in the South where
everything was required to be brick
period the end so make it three times as
expensive correct representative
Grant Maybe I'm Wrong here but reading
this um the mysticality May apply
aesthetic standards only if it's applied
those same standards to the original
dwelling so if they didn't apply any
standards to the original dwelling that
means they're out of luck at the way I'm
reading it yeah that's I yeah thank you
for pointing that
out represent Pig and then represent
buo thank you I was just going to
suggest that I think there's actually a
a lot of um interest in members of both
parties in this issue and that it's
something we could revisit next year in
new legislation I feel like our goal
should be to get a good version of this
bill through the best version we think
we can get through um and sounds like we
have a lot of or near consensus around
some of the issues around the misuse of
aesthetic standards so that would be
great to revisit but I would personally
say let's try to get it through
represent buia I was just going to say
that's actually really really
interesting reading of the bill because
if it says applied in the past tense so
if the original building was built when
there were no aesthetic standards you
would think it'd be grandfathered in
with no aesthetic
standards I mean I you know does
everybody else read it that way that's
it representative Dumont I'm just gonna
say I'm glad you guys can read
legislation like that because the boards
can't I don't I don't know how how often
you guys have gone to board meetings but
the the these logical consensus don't
normally happen uh there there's a lot
of good people they're volunteers I
understand that but there's so
much I'll I'll leave it alone I think if
we can push this forward fine I'm happy
with it it is definitely an improvement
but I will say that is going to be an
issue okay so to sum this
up I'm going to add this language about
the adoption of
zoning I'm going to add the language
about the square
footage I'm make a more clear sentence
about short-term
rentals although Bob did you have
something to add on
up um I'm going to move out the
effective date a
year
okay just put your um mic on I am Bob
Quinn I'm the CEO of the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors I haven't had a
chance to look at the language regarding
short-term rentals um this legislature
has debated this issue for a number of
years um has not come to any conclusions
yet it has been litigated in court uh in
New Hampshire time and time again both
Superior Court as well as the Supreme
Court what I read here would be a pretty
overarching change in uh policy in the
state so all I would suggest is a robust
discussion uh prior to doing that
the keep in mind that you know
short-term rentals we do see that's a
part of uh private property rights the
ability to rent out so a lot of property
owners do that in order to ensure that
they can stay in their homes uh and to
eliminate that as a possibility um we'll
have some serious repercussions we think
okay thank you I don't I don't think
anybody suggesting to deed restrict
these I think I think what we're
suggesting is giving the municipality
the option
of regulating it and you not supportive
of that it really does depend a lot on
the specific language okay um and whe
and how you go about doing that the
current statute right now does not
mention vacation rentals or short-term
rentals or anything else and that
statute has worked appropriately over
the past seven eight years so we're not
entirely clear why that needs to change
because we're going from attached to
detached okay
that's thank you that's helpful
you does anyone else have anything to
add on this bill represent buo I was
just kind of echo that that if this does
become something that maybe rightly or
wrongly but in the minds of other
Representatives becomes something that
is not just an Adu bill but also a
short-term rental bill you run the risk
of losing votes that you would have
otherwise got because you have
Representatives that say no but I don't
okay represent Dumont for the sake of
beating a dead horse I'm going to throw
out there one more time the secondary
access does anybody have any any
comments or concerns on that I can tell
you that it's a problem uh where I'm
there okay can you send me a sentence or
two on that
all right I think we're good on this
one next one is HB 631 permitting
Residential Building commercial zones by
right um I'll just start and say I
support the concept of it um I think the
home builders pointed out some clear
problems with the bill I also believe
there is
um a more clean version of this concept
on the our across the wall have maybe a
more clean version of this bill that um
I would suggest that we start with
that as a skeleton and then work off of
that I think less is more with a bill
like this um and I think this
one is going into too much detail is
muddying things up a little bit so
I I'd love to hear what the committee
the committee feels represent Axton well
in light of your comment and our prior
discussion would it be possible for the
committee to set aside discussion of
this bill until we have the Senate Bill
available to us in its current whatever
its current form is to review the two
side by
side can somebody get me a bill number
number okay representative Dumont yeah
the only thing I was going to add was
just T out some of the points that were
made in public hearing was definitely to
create a concise definition commercial
is just that of everything four units
are larger whether it be again a strip
mall or a multif family development or
an industrial complex certain towns have
specific zoning that call out those
commercial uses but not all towns so I
just think it'd be very important to
make sure that is clearly
defined that
0 all
um yeah so what I um what I think I want
to do is have a committee work session
on this bill next week after our public
hearings is there any opposition to
that um let's see when do we end next
week I believe I believe it's two so we
can have a quick committee work session
on that with with that version of the
bill and see and go from there does
anybody disagree with
that all right so I will schedule that
um and so the last bill I have on the
agenda is um HB 685 which is relative to
manufactured housing and residential
zones so I had handed uh out a uh a a
redlined although it's not color it's
not color coded but it's a Redline
version of
685 and allow me just a minute or two to
go over those uh recommended changes
so section 2 line 1314 States
notwithstanding any provision of law to
the contrary manufactured housing shall
be permitted in zones with area zoned
um the term residential zoned areas is
imprecise so what I want to do is um
switch it to land areas and lots and
District zone to permit residential uses
much shorter and more um
clear number two is section two line
1516 paragraph two doesn't address what
happens if municipality fails to amend
its zoning ordes so ensuring that a
manufactured housing is treated as
permitted in use in all man all
residential areas
um just adding that language in there
I actually don't think we necessarily
need that line
because if the municipality does not
amend their
zoning statute it's it is what it is the
state over the state trumps the
municipali zoning ordinances on that
representative
Howen just to that point to the
effective date is 60 days after passage
so the municipality wouldn't have time
to amend it yep so I would also so
another amendment would be to move out
the effective date but um I might
actually want to scratch line
1516 completely out of the next of the
vill he giving them a year to comply in
line
23 so who cares if it takes 60 days let
goes they have a year it does say that
said all municipalities shall amend
their zoning hes to comply with the
statute within six months the effective
date my um my red line would change it
to a year so even if the bill took
effect 60 days after passage they would
still have a full year to amend their
zoning ordinances and even if they
didn't the that's the law I mean the
that's what the state said so uh
representative
Gibbs I would prefer to keep uh lines 15
and 16 requiring that Municipal
municipalities change their zoning
ordinances and certainly you know give
them a year to do it that's reasonable
um if you don't do that I think you're
inviting litigation and there's no need
to invite any more litigation than
necessary well I I I agree with that I
think think there's other like things
that we did last year for instance the
parking we changed parking last year and
now in March in Goffstown we're voting
on amending our zoning ordinances to
update with the state the state New
definition of what what they require for
parking and the way I read it is even if
that warrant didn't pass that would be
the law anyways the the municipality
would just have a conflicting with the
law but in this situation the state law
trumps the municipal
orians that's what that that's how I'm
reading it I don't think I don't think
it would be very uh uous L litigation I
think that's pretty clear but go ahead
repres I I agree um the problem is that
if the municipality said no we have our
we have our zoning ordinance and we're
going to enforce it and then the um uh
property owner would have to go to court
um to say no the state law trumps and
the state state law would Trump but you
it is anybody opposed with leaving it in
I mean I don't I don't necessarily think
it's necessary but go ahead represent
Dumont I was going to say I'm fine with
it either way I think that I think they
both work fine I mean state law at the
end of the day is what will take set
precedent so okay and then the last
change I have in my red line is on line
2526 it would Scratch Out represent
Daxton asked during the public hearing
he's like who's the State Department of
Housing and Urban Development and I was
like oh that's that's a good point and I
don't really want to necessarily um rely
on the federal government to do anything
so um leaving them out of
the legislation and the the law would be
good so um kind of wondering what the
proposed representive Aon uh my concern
with this bill is how many manufactured
homes can you put on a lot because uh
Charlestown has a lot of trailer parks
and they have a huge tax problem so you
need to be able to let a municipality
decide no trailer
parks so if you want to put a
manufactured home on your own lot that's
fine no problem but if you want to put
20 of them in there that should be uh up
to the municipality to permit that right
and that's what this bill does so it it
updates the definition of manufactured
housing on a permanent chassis but
additionally this just says single
family residentially zoned areas
so if it Zone single family you couldn't
put more than one on there that that
makes sense so it that should alleviate
your concern with that thank you
represent
paig I'm supportive okay you're just
asking for input
he supportive with this
amendment all right so I'm going to get
this drafted too and hopefully we can
get um this bill out next
um next Tuesday so I'll probably pull it
up during executive session at some
point
um that's what I have
for um bills for the work session I had
a couple bills to exec I want to see
where we're missing one Republican and
yeah I'm gonna I'm going to yep I'm
going to recess until 11:30 and then I
AB
e
I'll be honest like you're trying
was
e
309 I handed an amendment to the
committee earlier um 0342 is is there a
second to that motion I second that
representative mil seconds it so real
quickly um I thought we saw that there
was um a little there was Merit to this
um by requiring at least one
non-electronic form of payment um this
amendment would just add to lines um
after after section one of the bill oh
inserted by it would just replace
section one of the bill um to say that
the landlord shall allow at least at
least one other non- electronic form of
payment for the purposes of this section
I just think it makes it more clear um
and I think it addresses the concerns
raised by the sponsor of the bill and it
moves the bill forward so are there are
amendment great represent paage just
noting my support I think this is just a
clarification rather than a change in
intent okay um so with that um we need
to I'll just do a show of hands for the
amendment so you don't need to take a
roll on this um all those in favor of
adopting Amendment 2025 0342 raise your
hand
now those opposed all right we're uh
that was adopted you can just make a
note that that was adopted um 17 to
Z and so now we're on the emotion motion
of ought to pass as amended I made that
motion it was second by represent miles
any discussion on
this all right seeing
CL Vice chairman Cole
yes representative Faxton yes
representative
Aaron yes representative buer yes
representative Dumont yes representative
Grant yes representative m miles yes
representative Miner not here clerk
reinford yes representative Paige yes
representative boras yes representative
Reed yes representative Gibbs yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative hegner yes
representative Kerwin yes Mr chair Mr
chair
yes all right it's adopted 17 to zero um
so I'm going to I'm going to delegate
representative miles to write the report
can you get that to me um by the end of
today we're going to be we're going to
be gone
yeah like we're we're we're leaving
we're leaving before lunch so you have
the entire afternoon to write a quick
report um any any opposition with this
going on
consent all right great next up I want
to open the executive session on HB 350
1 and I would like to recognize
representative Faxton for a
motion my motion would be itl is there a
second representative Cole seconds it
ahead uh I don't think expanding the
notice to tenants to 60 days is
necessary I think uh there's adequate
current
protections and it may actually be in
conflict with uh other parts of the
landlord tenant law because the current
law as my understanding of it is I was
trying to look it up quickly is that the
notice to a tenant is
actually uh determined by the length of
the normal rental payment
interval uh so if you have someone who
rents on a weekly basis and those
tenants do exist in this state uh the
the notice to them is one week uh if you
have someone who rents semiannually or
annually it would be that period of time
so my concern is but if we adopted this
you would be muddying the water in
everything other than what we think of
as a standard rental of 30
days representative Reed thank you Mr
chair um I am opposed to the itl motion
I'm opposed because we currently um give
tenants who are in month-to-month situ
situations 30 days notice of a rent
increase and uh of an
eviction that has the potential and and
I would like to remind everybody some
people 70% of tenants are in
month-to-month agreements some of those
Agreements are over a decade or maybe
you know two decades so it's not like
you ended your lease and now
everything's up in the air you may have
been stable for years and years and all
of a sudden your landlord wants to evict
you now we just as the committee and as
the entire body said that in some cases
we want to give people 60 days notice we
enshrined 60 days notice so I think that
60-day notice should um in fact I think
there was a press release that kind of
implied that all evictions now had 60
days notice and that was weird because
that's not what we did as a body as I
recall but I think we should I think we
should give everybody who were going to
evict a 60-day notice because finding a
new place especially in this market is
incredibly difficult
and if there are any inconsistencies
which I I actually don't think there are
and the current 608 noes by the way
applies to six month leases um then I
think that that should be amended so I
am in support in this 0.6% vacancy of
giving people 60 days notice because
it's going to take at least that long to
find a cardboard box to live in well
thank you thank you for your um for
speaking on that I think you're
confusing a termination of lease with an
eviction so I just want I just want to
clarify for the committee this is this
has nothing to do with the termination
of lease that we just passed no I I I
know it's a different bill and I
understand the difference between the
two bills this bill gives a 60-day
notice of eviction for people who are
out of their lease specifically if
you're in a month-to-month agreement and
then the landlord evicts you for another
cause we now having passed the house
created a new cause of eviction so that
60 notice that you give under the new
termination of lease or you know your
that is a an eviction notice a 60-day
eviction notice the cause is termination
of lease the cause listed on the
eviction notice is termination of lease
but it is a notice of eviction that they
get 60 days so now we have one cause of
eviction that we're giving 60 days to a
cause that we never had before and now
we have all the other causes that we're
not giving 60 days to and that 60 days
apply the one that we just passed
applies to even six-month leases
so it's not even based on the the tency
so having said that that's why I support
it what was in a press release implied
that we were giving tenets protections
comments all right seeing none clerk
call
roll Vice chairman Cole yes representa
Faxton yes representative Aaron yes
representative Boler yes representative
Dumont yes representative Grant yes
representative miles yes representative
Miner not here clerk reinford yes
Representative paig
no representative bores no
representative Reed no representative
Gibbs no representative Hicks no
representative Howland no Representative
hegner no representative Kerwin no chair
Alexander
yes yep motion carries 9
to8 um uh this will go on the regular
calendar and I'm going to have uh
representative Daxton write the majority
report and will there be a majority
report representative Reed will write a
Minority Report representative Reed
stepping on up we'll write The Minority
Report
okay and the last bill I would like to
EXA today is HB 628 relative to
prohibiting landlords from
discriminating against prospective
tenants holding certain vouchers under
housing Choice Voucher Program I'd like
to call and represent bolo for a
motion Mr chairman I move uh an
expedient to legislate is there a second
second representative Cole seconds
discussion go
ahead yeah so on on this one I think
this one will actually set up sort of an
perverse incentive to raise rent or to
have um you know other costs passed on
to other tenants um there was quite a
bit of opposition when it came to
testimony um it also forces landlords to
sign a government contract and it could
lead to an increase in rents with a
reduction in
quality um so I I really think that uh
it really should be up to landlords
themselves to decide whether or not they
want to get involved with um you know
some of these voucher
programs representative howand
so so I actually brought this up because
there was no sponsor and we've run into
an issue when we did our Workforce
housing
overlay and it's I think what was
brought up is like somebody who had the
voucher didn't have enough money to pay
for what the market rate rent was and
that the the ATT tenant uh couldn't pay
the difference and I went to Hud's
website and that they said they could it
may different on different vouchers HUD
definitely doesn't want to do that cuz
it's inflationary in terms of like
rental rates if you start saying okay
you can pay $50 more than your voucher
then it'll raise the local area rents
why I brought this up is that um
Workforce housing rental statute and uh
fair market rental which is the top of
the voucher they're not calculated the
same the fair market rent which the
voucher is done is 40% of the median uh
rents in your area and then the
workforce hous is based on your
percentage of area median income and
what we've seen right now because local
rents are really high believe it or not
the fair market rent which is the
voucher is higher than is for the uh
Workforce standard um I had it down in
here with uh I wrote the number down in
my notes it's about call it
1950 for fair market the top of the
voucher right now in straford County but
when you do like Workforce housing it's
only like 1,800 and so for us we were in
this perverse situation which one of
these do we use when we put our
Workforce housing which were requiring a
certain amount to be in statute or into
our local ordinance and so we we didn't
want to not use the voucher and we
wanted to be in compliance with the
workforce we ended up going and do as
well has gone with fair market rental
just because if it changes then we
wouldn't say you can't accept the
voucher and so it really creates
uncertainty and I can see from your
faces that it's increas causing
uncertainty there it's really weird
because the two standards are not the
same so in essence when we did the
workforce housing overlay and we used
fair market rent we could rent to
everybody with a voucher and not be in
compliance with our Workforce housing
statute so I just if we have a notebook
of things to look at for like next term
that's something that maybe we would
want to look up and that's why I brought
representative we have a whole another
year to file house bills so not even
next term sorry I mean I I just wanted
to have it on the table that's why I
brought it up great thank you
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um I just want
to add to the discussion um what I said
uh during our last discussion on this
bill and that is that by discriminating
uh against people with vouchers um uh
the landlord is thereby discriminating
against families with children and
people with
disabilities let representative I I
don't understand your line of
questioning during the public hearing
because th those don't have to be mutual
exclusive not every person that has a
voucher has children and not every
person that has a voucher is disabled
they are disabled people that don't have
vouchers that cannot be discriminated
against there are be there are you can't
discriminate already in law based on
famili familiar status so I'm I'm trying
I was trying to be patient during the
public hearing but I really was confused
what your what your point was there uh
my point was that a discriminatory
effect is
discrimination and because there are
more PE more families with children and
more people with disabilities who have
vouchers there's a discriminatory effect
in against families with children and
against people with disabilities by
discriminating against
vouchers thank you representative
Reed thank you Mr chair um I'm grateful
for the
conversation that uh rep buolo and rep
Howen started having around rent seeking
Behavior which is I guess unfortunately
a pun but I brought it up during the
hearing and rent-seeking behavior is
when the private Market takes advantage
of either a handout or another
guaranteed um source of income and
raises prices to take advantage of that
that's rent-seeking behavior and um it's
true that when you have some sort of
public handout if you don't put a cap
then people the private Market will
engage in rent-seeking behavior and that
will be inflationary so it in because of
that logic I would have suggested that
you all go with the workforce housing
not the fair market um I was like why
did you do that so I I'm appreciative of
of that um and that problem having said
that there are landlords in fact
landlords who have testified before us
who in my own town have engaged because
they do take vouchers in that exact rent
seeking Behavior and the more the
voucher goes up the more they raise the
rent right and they raise it to just
enough above the difference that the
people can afford constantly every
single time even though their costs
haven't gone up so that is a problem
that needs to be dealt with anytime you
create a a a program that gives people
uh monetary assistance for a particular
item having said that I am still in
favor of the bill um the way I would put
it and I think representative Gibbs is
trying to get to this point but we heard
from a different landlord not the one
that I just referenced we heard a
comment from that landlord directly
saying that if you take away our ability
to discriminate on the basis of
vouchers we then would not legally be
able to determine who fits in our
community and those were the words he
used so that is basically admitting that
he wants to engage and other I'm meaning
it generally because there are other
landlords I'm not all landlords but
there are landlords out there who want
to engage in what we currently consider
illegal
discrimination and the only legal tool
they currently have is to discriminate
on the form of payment and so for that
reason I support the bill although I do
acknowledge the rent sinking Behavior
problem
other
comments all right seeing none we'll
have um the clerk call the
role the motion is um
itl Vice chairman Cole
yes representative Faxton yes
representative Aaron yes representative
bullier yes representative jont yes
representative Grant yes representative
miles yes
representative Miner not here clerk
reinford yes representative Paige no
Representative boras no representative
Reed no representative Gibbs no
representative Hicks no representative
Howland no Representative hegner no
representative Kerwin no chairman
Alexander
yes motion passes 9 to8
um representative bolo will you write
the majority report all right and will
there be a Minority Report yes
representative Gibbs would you be
willing to write The Minority Report on
this
one thank you okay representative Gibbs
and buolo if you can get that to me by
11:59 p.m. that' be great and I will
review that tomorrow morning or at
midnight we'll see how late late I'm up
tonight okay is there any other business
to come before the housing committee I
know that um representative Howland has
a um subcommittee work session I'm sorry
at 2 o' so you got a couple couple hours
off
um have a yeah a nice Hefty lunch if you
want um any other business come before
the committee okay so next week we have
four public hearings I'm going to notice
for exec sessions just in case um and I
will confer with um representative paig
on drafting Amendment
um and I will also have an amendment for
a couple bills um and then I'm also
going to call on repes Representatives
Dumont and Howland next week to have an
amendment on HB
296 that is uh par our discussion
today anything else all right great
go
e
to to try to override what is in essence
of bad bad zoning and so I mean I my
mind is always
like I know no zoning ordinance is
perfect but you want to try to keep the
number of variances to a minimum if
you're doing a good job if you have a
lot of variances coming in then fix your
zoning ordinance and so when I the key
thing that I came through with the the
uh thing that came to us is that it uh
Property Owners shall be allowed to
build on their property without seeking
a variance and so when I read it what
they're really trying to say is that the
houses around them are a certain way and
they want the right to do what people
did in that neighborhood clearly
something changed in the zoning that
wasn't really
effective so I I tried to grab somewhat
off of what was in our partners bill
which is that uh that patterns of zoning
and so just the basic concept I said is
that uh if you allow the governing body
to put in an ordinance that says land
owners are allowed to build on smaller
Lots if the massing and fronting are
consistent with the existing
neighborhood is what the idea is um the
couple of challenges I had in there is
that you'd have to figure out what the
massing the the in that um enabling
legislation they would have to put in
what are permitted massing and and
frontages and then the second
thing which we already discussed which
is more problematic is what exactly
constitutes a neighborhood I'm a little
nervous if you're going over zones and
you're saying well this is a huge thing
I'm allowed here and this I'm not can I
allow it so so I think that's enough for
my my sense and I'll just throw it out
I just think a th000 ft is pretty big
it's like you know and again I I just I
mean I talked to somebody who's uh the
chair of of Enfield and he said do it
like three houses on either side or
something like that I I'm not quite I
mean that's a sticking point to me
exactly
defining what you're allowing I was
going to say within a Zone because I I
think um in my mind we have one in
Durham that is the faculty neighborhood
and it had much smaller lots and you
can't do that anywhere else so so I'm
I'm kind of stuck I'm looking for
guidance but wouldn't a Zone be bigger
than a th000 ft it could be
yeah but you've already kind of defined
so it has to be something specific
that's clear enough um and I don't know
me yeah I would say that I would agree I
think that you have to have some nomial
number only because of what we talked
about before at least in Hudson we have
a lot of zones that they just threw a
line down in the middle of neighborhoods
or they were just you know they were
drone drawn all over the place they
didn't actually run in any matter that
made sense so for me that's where I was
looking at that I think that that's
where this creates a concern is where
you have on one hand the neighborhood
was built a certain way and fits that
zone or they and they drew a line right
through it and the guy next door is now
stuck conforming to something that
really does fit in the neighborhood per
se so since I have it saying that this
is enabling and your local governing
body is going to do that they could set
that because I think the best person to
the best group to decide what a
neighborhood is is likely your local
municipality so if they set what the
standard is I mean it could be in some
some municipalities a neighborhood may
be 500 feet in some neighborhoods it may
be a th000 feet so I think what you'd
ask is in the legis in the ordinance it
would designate what that area is as
well and then what that meant in terms
of massing and Frontage but isn't this
bill intended to limit what the
municipality can do that that is to say
we have to allow more density than the
municipality might otherwise
allow it is and I think what we're I'm
so in my brain what I was thinking is we
have another piece of legislation that's
saying that in res residential zones you
can't
do uh more than half an acre but in a
lot of our residential zones a half an
acre is really really big and so what
I'm really looking at is a way not to
get a variance but a way that you can as
long as you as long as you look like the
rest of the neighborhood you can build
on a smaller lot so this is supposed to
allow you to do more than you could ex
exact exactly that but you need
something specific to De to find the
area that you intend to cover and just
to say
neighborhood it's too
wishy-washy um you're going to have
endless argument about that and honestly
it will allow the municipality to Define
neighborhoods in such a way that it
would limit the density anyway so I I
have to say I think that there would be
that I I I would Echo representative
Gibbs comments um I I think that's a
that's a good point you know one of the
ways cuz I'm I'm thinking about
ultimately what is the goal of this bill
and what this bill wants to allow is if
you have a lot that let's say was
subdivided back in the day and then you
had new zoning or zoning imposed and now
you have this lot which is ex
essentially undevelopable so a a way to
put those lots back into use to where
they can be used in a way that is
similar to what is already there so I
was thinking about what if what if
instead of doing the neighborhood
density kind of test maybe keep that as
a test maybe even with you know
Municipal municipality weighing in on it
but then also have a separate way that
you can get to um density Conformity
without a variance and I was thinking of
two different ways one of which is to
say well if you have an AB budding lot
that has a certain amount of density
then you can also build on your
neighboring lot as long as your density
does not exceed what your neighbor
already has so that would automatically
whatever your neighbor has would be
something in the neighborhood so you
would automatically as of right be very
easy to figure out this is the max
density I can have on this and
presumably that developed lot was you
know developed you know in Conformity
with the neighborhood the second thing
you could do is you could also say um
you are allowed to have the density as
was allowed when the lot was first
subdivided well on your your first um
suggestion um why does it have to be an
udding lot I mean it seems to make more
sense to me to say um the nearby three
or four Lots which I think the a thou
the thousand foot area would cover
rather than just you know by Chance the
abing lot matches or it doesn't match
that doesn't seem very fair and
then how it was when it was originally
subdivided it might take a lot of effort
to find that out you know it might have
been done in
1920 and it would take a lot of
searching through the records to find
that and also it was a different world
in 1920 I don't know that we really that
we want to put all of that weight on
1920 so I like a lot of the points have
been brought up one of the thing that I
would like the the subcommittee to
consider is lots that weren't subdivided
but lie within those neighborhoods that
maybe now if they were to build today
they're only able to get one but you may
able to get two or three homes out of
that which would really help the the the
housing crisis that we're in um so for
me I wouldn't tie it to just existing
Lots I would tie it to kind of what my
view of the original Bill's intent was
to say that if there's land within this
neighborhood that you can make conform
to the neighborhood then you should be
allowed to build on it based on those on
those on that density uh for me I think
the thousand feet will throw at a couple
things uh I think a th000 feet is a lot
smaller when you when you hear it it
sounds like a very far distance when you
actually drive it or walk down the road
it's not very far um I would say that
you almost run it like a buffer where
you say 1,000 feet from the property
lines instead of just a a random uh dot
that you're throwing on on a map um I
would say that it has to go with uh lot
size and Frontage not just because
without Frontage the lot size doesn't
mean anything in my Appo in my opinion
um and then the other thing that I would
say is that I think it that Conformity
should be based on a majority I I don't
think 90% um I don't think 90% is fair
quite frankly originally I was thinking
onethird but I didn't think that would
get too much traction so I could agree
on a majority and then as for who
controls it in line 16 I think it should
be based on the zoning administrator or
permit technician uh because that would
be the the department that would have to
check that box off anyways um and then
that way when somebody files for this it
just simply it goes through staff
approval those are good ideas I age so I
I to to your point of like looking at
what the it was when it was first sub I
asked that question because I was like
what if we did it in like 19 and they
actually pulled it right up it was the
town does have records of all that you
do keep records of all your zoning so
you could answer that and I I assumed
that you would go back to kind of what
was the most permissive uh when it was
done but I do like your idea if you said
you you could go back and find out what
what the ordinance that allowed the
majority of the the the in your buffer
zone that that that would be permitted
and that it had to meet though but it
had to meet those requirements it had to
meet the frontage and it had to meet the
lot
size that makes that makes a lot of
sense and I think the idea of making it
a th000 feet from the property line is
also a good idea because that specifies
exactly where it is whereas the end of
the house might be different for each
Builder but the property line is the
proper
line yeah and I just wanted to mention a
th000 ft that's that's less than a
quarter mile that's pretty pretty tight
I can tell you like up in the North
Country I mean 1,000 ft I mean you're
going to be still in the same
neighborhood in most places so I I I
think it's I think it's pretty tight one
of one of my suggestions and I like your
you know where you're thinking um in
terms of um representative Dumont with
the with the zoning administrator and
the majority um you know of the
properties within that thous foot radius
from the property line um so I I what I
was proposing was let's have different
ways to check this box we can have one
way that you can satisfy this by The
Neighborhood um you know existing
density and then another one by what was
allowed historically you know that way
you have um you know more than more than
one way to easily discern whether or not
it's
allowed so can I ask you so back to this
because I I do like the idea that it
just goes to like it's administrative
approval rather than you have to go back
to the planning board so would you be
okay that if we said yes you could use
ex I I think you're saying you're AB
budding is a good one with me AB budding
historically what the majority of the
neighborhood and I'm fine with your
thousand feet even though as we move to
like Portsmith a th000 feet gets to be
really big but that either existing or
you know AB budding or historically it
was okay it could go to administrative
but it was approved by your local
governing body are you okay with
that so you saying for them to develop a
policy Within These within these
standards and for their approval um I I
mean I would say that if if that was the
way the majority here felt then I would
be okay with that because I think that's
a step in the right direction but I
think what this bill's intent was is to
say you guys tried it and it didn't work
here's a here's a solution from from our
point of view um so I'm kind of up in
the air I guess on that on that part of
it because I'm just not sure that you'll
see them adopting it that's that's my
only
thing do we maybe want to for because I
I think what you're getting at is a
th000 feet is too much for for your part
of the state yeah so what if we do a
compromise where I mean th000 ft works
great you know where I am but maybe say
if it's a um you know if it's a town
that has a per capita density above a
certain amount or if it's a census
designated urban area or something
tighten it up a little bit would that
help yeah I'm I just don't know what the
I feel like I'm throwing a dart I don't
know what the number is for me I think
that over complicates it I'll be I'll be
right up front with you um I I got to
I'm going to stand strong and I don't
think that a th000 ft is a lot I will
even at as in one of Hudson's most dense
neighborhoods and I talk to you about
this is is our traditional residential
which is 90 ft of Frontage so we're
talking about 10 homes that you're that
you're going by that's less than a
street in most cases so for me it that
fits the neighborhood and you know I
brought up an example earlier uh to
represent Howland that in Hudson we had
a case where they just drew a business
district line right through tra
traditional residential and if that
person was to not be owed to go outside
of the zone and and compile this
information they would have had to
either put a gas station or a multif
family development inside a traditional
residential Zone just because somebody
threw a line through the middle of the
neighborhood per se so that's why I
think it's important to have that
thousand feet in my mind I would
recommend sticking with a thousand feet
that sounds reasonable it isn't that big
I I don't think I mean I I mean
ultimately we're just trying to get
houses on smaller Lots isn't that what
we're trying to do
I think for this one it's to make houses
conform uh to the neighborhood so I
don't know I mean yeah they essentially
I guess they would be smaller than what
they're what they're asking for today
but really you're just making them the
same as what's already there yeah I mean
again as I my point about that too you
it's it's the lot is smaller but if you
do control the massing and the frontage
it'll fit within the neighborhood right
so it's like as long as the house can so
you know if you have a really small a
lot you may not be able to build your
3,000 ft house there but you could fit a
1200t house that's situated with the
right front edge and it it would fit
right in it's just a smaller
house yeah to that point that's exactly
what I envisioned is that with the same
density in Frontage you're going to have
similar building envelopes which would
then dictate the size of the house that
could be put on
there see if I can tie this all together
because I think what I really want to do
is to try to write it up and then we can
look at it and you guys can do the fun
of word smithing so so let me just
clarify would this be the state is
dictating you have to do this or is it
like would you go you want the
municipality to adopt
this I think we're saying the state is
saying you have to do this okay I would
say since in essence a variance the
criteria for variance is set by the
state that there can't be a reason why
the state gives an alternative to that
okay so it's state mandated let me start
with that uh number two is that uh the
criteria for uh for doing it uh is that
it has to be consistent with the the
majority of the
existing uh homes in the neighborhood
which we're defining as a th000 square
feet a th000 square feet I I to % of
Gibbs point I would just eliminate the
word I me and not that I'm saying get
away from the but just eliminate the
word and say within a th a th000 feet of
the property lines th000 feet of
property line that's good and then to
yours uh point it uh H it you could use
either because you had two criteria it
was either within 1,000 ft what was the
majority of the property is within a
th000 square ft of the
property line within a th000 ft I think
making a th000 sareet too complicated
th000 ft or that you could show
historically that in the past it was
allowed in zoning is that does that
yes in terms of historic um you know
neighborhoods and what was you know
allowed historically in terms of
historic preservation I mean you are
literally going to what the historic
standards were so at least in terms of
density not in terms of building quality
or anything like that okay I I think I
got is there any I mean I think that
does that cover it the only thing that I
would like to make sure that's in there
from my perspective is that it should
you know line 16 should read the local
zoning administrator or permit
technician um I only throw Perman
technician in there because I know some
towns have somebody that goes through
all those documents Hudson has a zoning
administrator um the local zoning
administrator perit technician shall be
responsible for verifying that the
proposed building um um
Lots uh conform to the density
requirements under this section okay
that's good I like that because that
means then theoretically as long as you
can if you put in your
application that administrator checks
and says it's okay then you can build it
right
yeah I think that c so I'll write this
up and I'll uh I guess the best thing
I'm supposed to do is send it to Joe
yeah and then ask him how he wants us we
probably should meet one more time just
to look over it and yeah you could do a
a first read or you could do a you know
a reading a vote um typically on the
local level we have a first read of that
final uh document and then we vote after
but however everybody sees fit we're the
same we do like we actually we're more
painful we do first read and second read
but nonetheless I want to make sure
everybody that we got the language right
before we do any voting I like that all
right I think that was it record time
thank
you um so are we going to meet after the
next um housing committee
meeting I have to ask the boss how this
actually operates but at least let me
put together the language every and
everything and then I'll ask him how he
wants to approach when we meet because I
don't know what the meeting schedule's
going to be
like yeah and I just like to add that um
meeting after the main committee
meetings works really well for me um so
I'd like to continue that although
hopefully maybe tighten it our lunch
break up a little bit I I have great
respect for all of you that are
gainfully employed and that we try to
make it as efficient as humanly possible
so I'll try with
that and the next meeting is scheduled
for for the 18th so it could be after
that
I'll
ask
e